[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka a friendly
neighborhood spider-man and we've been
getting a whole host of new leaked
images for the upcoming Black Widow
movie that tease that everything is not
as it seems throughout this video I'm
going to be breaking down the new behind
the scenes photos of general Ross and
how it confirms several things about the
film now there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you aren't fully caught up
with the MCU then I highly suggest that
you turn off now we'll be going over one
of the biggest moments in Avengers
endgame to get a beer and go play some
fall night instead if you don't want
anything spoiled if you're still here I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our theory breakdown okay so one of the
biggest moments in Avengers endgame
centered around black widows death after
she sacrificed herself in order to get
the soul stone from Boromir though the
Avengers tried to bring the character
back it was to no avail and she still
remained dead at the close of the movie
though they never gave her a funeral
which is always a big sign that she's
still alive
anyway this left some people scratching
their heads as her upcoming film the
aptly titled Black Widow has a release
date of 2020 now from the trailers shown
at Comic Con and the confirmation that
Tony Stark will have a cameo in the film
we know that the majority of the movie
will be set right after the events of
civil war with Widow going on the run
from the government for aiding cap and
Bucky in their escape however there are
some new behind the scenes photos that
have just reached the internet that
confirm the film will be more than
simply just a prequel the images that
leaked to the reddit thread Marvel
Studios spoilers show a much much older
and frailer general Ross and if this is
due to take place immediately after
Civil War and before infinity war then
it's safe to assume that he had a pretty
tough paper round during that time
however it does look like it indeed
confirms that parts of the film at the
very least will be taking place after
the events of Avengers endgame in which
the character will have aged five years
look a lot older if this is the case
then I'd say there's a lot more weight
to the theory that Black Widow is
actually alive after the events of
endgame and that the world isn't aware
of it personally I believe that the
ending of his solo outing will show her
waking up and Boromir
after the Hulk's snap brings her back
whilst the big Green Giant believed that
he failed if he had have succeeded
there's no way that he would have known
as her body would still be on Boromir in
2014 this behind-the-scenes photo shows
that we will at least get details on the
current state of the MCU with Ross
potentially learning of her return now
there's one of two ways I think this
could go either we cut in etosha waking
up on the planet and then cut to black
in the post-credits scene or we follow
cap arriving on Boromir to return the
soul stone and he either exchanges it
for her life or discovers that her body
is no longer there I definitely think
that if this solo filmed as well the
marble will want to continue with the
character and it doesn't make sense for
widow to just have a standalone movie in
a franchise that's full of trilogies and
crossovers now there are also theories
that this could actually be a tease of
the Red Hulk in which an aging Ross who
in the comics becomes the character ends
up being experimented on as a way to
prolong his life this itself could be
the post-credits scene and it may tease
the introduction of the Thunderbolts
this also makes a lot of sense and it
could also prove to be correct with this
being a big step towards the rumored Red
Hulk film that is currently flowing
about the Internet personally I'm very
excited by this image and I'm glad that
the film will at least in some form or
another
tell the present situation of the Marvel
Universe instead of simply being a
retread over what we already know
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this image and if you agree with my
theory or have a completely different
one comment below and let me know and if
you enjoy this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the rapport that the chameleon will
be the villain in the upcoming
spider-man 3 movie I go over everything
that you need to know about this story
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to come
chat to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I'll see you over there after
this also just want to let you know that
are currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far
and blu-ray and all you have to do to be
in with a chance of winning is to like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on these images in the comment section
below the woman will be chosen at random
on October the 15th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from the intimate gets
the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care
peace
[Music]